Lyon aisle or city kids who never had
big backyards but we'll always have each
other some friendships are so important
you do anything to make them last that's
why you I and I created the no-kiss list
the official insurance against Naomi T
right break up friendship where we never
fight over guys
Gabriel so belongs in a no-kiss list
do you know how much easier my life if
Eli is gay that's never gonna change
Higuchi too but not too good Oh Canada
that's you big guy after you drink I
really shouldn't have done that I kissed
your boyfriend yeah you never put him on
the note kissless some things are just
obvious trick or treat house in the
neighborhood Jimmy Clausen
I am so flattered you put my needs over
the needs of my boyfriend well I think
it's safe to say he's not your boyfriend
anymore
Feli doesn't believe in little kiss list
anyway
really Naomi that skirt as if it since
2010 hater fighting feel it so fasting
know me your sofa
what's the words though what you have to
Breakfast at Tiffany's you know I'm
crazy about Tiffany's
these lies
I know you think all this crap with you
is like the worst thing that ever
happened there's a lot more out there
for you than you realize if you're ready
for it we don't feel better in the
morning
actually no that's I'm sure you're gonna
feel worse I can't predict you a doctor
I'm a doorman
see Anita's Carla's ich heiße near kinda
party who beset by young machine broken
city image the photo / tomorrow
- verse McNish to Berlin